[Música]
eu queria falar vos hoje uma das coisas
que eu gosto mais de fazer que é o
teatro do oprimido que atua o primeiro
foi criado por um senhor brasileiro nos
anos 60 ou 70 entre os anos 60 e 70
eu não vou contar a história toda disse
apenas que é uma forma de intervenção
através do teatro e que cresceu alguns
qual fazia era criar cenas a partir das
histórias das pessoas e por via do
teatro ensaiar as formas de transformar
essas cenas
o curioso é que o augusto boal que tinha
estado no brasil teve que se exilar por
causa da ditadura brasileira
em algum momento em que vai vencê lá pra
europa e em paris começou a fazer
oficinas e perguntar às pessoas com quem
fazia essas oficinas quais eram as suas
opções e quem eram os seus opressores e
aí eu estava habituado que dissessem
coisas como o meu absorção a polícia que
chegou a meio da noite vai ficar meu
marido eu vou para uma prisão do tutor
ou ou camponeses que diziam os nós só
estamos fazendo isso mandaram matar os
nossos companheiros e eu que estava
habituado a ouvir essas histórias em
paris nas oficinas
havia gente que respondia coisas tão
caricatos como eu sinto uma primeira por
meio do vazio ou então só os que diziam
que eu acho que os meus opressores sou
eu próprio não fazia não parece fazer
sentido nenhum
mas é uma história engraçada que o canta
de uma oficina em paris de uma pessoa de
uma mulher que tinha sido problema
ela tinha visto numa loja a caminho do
metro vestido vermelho que tinha durado
e então andou alguns meses a juntar
dinheiro para comprar e assistido
momento em que conseguiu comprar esse
estilo o voltei pra casa super feliz
neste novo ela adorava que o stilo
vermelho e no dia em que se viu na noite
em que seria o que utilizar aqui um
sentido positivo pois enfrenta a espanha
é para ela visitar
ficar com dúvidas mas ganhou coragem
saiu de casa
bata à porta volta pra casa tirou o
vestido em outra roupa e sai com outra
roupa
isso aconteceu uma vez duas vezes três
vezes
ninguém dizia não pode ser assistido na
cela que tinha comprado um indivíduo
vestido que estava eu não conseguia ter
coragem para autorizar o desafio do gol
foi o seguinte eu disser é essa senhora
proposto que pensasse quais eram os voz
que quando ela estava sozinha enfrentar
os pais lhe diziam não pode dizer-se
estiva
era a voz do pai dela que dizia que ela
não podia ser assim pra rua
era a voz do do por exemplo a pessoa tem
porque o comandante polícia de toronto
reagindo aos casos de violações no
campus universitário disse que as
mulheres têm que fazer para evitar
violações é deixarem justiça computadas
tornando os culpados do crime que era
feito os crimes que são feitos contra
elas
era a voz do do namorado que não queria
que ela fosse assim não precisa ir a uma
festa era o anúncio visão que fazia
sentir gorda quando ela olhava os tons
para qualquer destino era o que era a
memória daquela que solte um dia não vou
tocar com a cide ou era essa pessoa que
estava dentro da cabeça dela sob a forma
de um medo antecipado poderia
objectivamente acontecer quando ela sair
à rua com o estilo até do qual é é
simples na verdade se chama estas vozes
que estão dentro da nossa cabeça os
polícias da cabeça
nós entre exames estas vozes e ao fazê
lo a fazer uns isso internalizamos a
opção só que essas vozes não mexam
conosco
elas vivem dentro de nós a gente fora de
nós e tem uma origem na sociedade
na verdade o nosso corpo vivo está no
mundo social mas o mundo social também
está dentro do nosso corpo sob a forma
de as polícias na cabeça do esquema
são formas de pensamento categorias
através das quais pensamos o mundo e
licitações do que vai acontecer
exposições e se nós olharmos para o modo
como os reproduz ordem social
nós encontramos basicamente dois
mecanismos um é coerção quando alguém
nos fóruns quando alguém de fora nos
obriga a fazer qualquer coisa
o outro é o consentimento quando nós
aceitamos ou decidimos fazer alguma
coisa
no caso da coerção é fácil ver quem é
que está a dar essa ordem portanto é
fácil identificar
eventualmente quando está no caso do
consentimento nós entre utilizamos é tal
ponto essa ordem que vamos achar que
somos nós os nossos próprios opções e às
vezes agir como tal
escusado será dizer que do ponto de
vista do controle social
o consentimento é muito mais eficaz que
a correção e não sei se nós já nos
apercebemos do poder desse mecanismo
mas o sistema econômico há muito tempo
que se percebeu de se poder só dois
exemplos o exemplo a idéia do atual
emprego tendo sido apresentada como
reino da liberdade ninguém manda em nós
nós temos os nossos próprios patrões
basta ter uma ideia fazer um negócio
vamos provavelmente ganhar mais ter mais
tempo perfeito mas muitos de nós sabemos
a nossa própria custa que nem sempre é
assim que às vezes essa promessa da
autonomia acaba por transformar se numa
falácia
muitas vezes acontece que um trabalhador
independente acaba por trabalhar muito
mais tempo porque não há limite nós
normalmente não somos muito bons patrões
para nós próprios e acaba puro trabalhar
em que as condições porque não têm
dinheiro e frequentemente a pagar mais
impostos porque ao mesmo tempo seu
trabalhador eo empresário de si próprio
mas há outros exemplos e um exemplo bem
curioso é o exemplo do tempo e vou falar
do tempo
porque o tempo é nada mais nada menos do
que o bem mais precioso que nós temos é
o bem mais escasso que nós temos uma
razão muito evidentes é que nós somos
finitos e é por isso que é em grande
medida continua a ser em torno do tempo
que se jogam as grandes questões da
nossa vida há mais de 100 anos em uma
quinta-feira de 1890
houve 11 conjunto de milhares de
operários que traçaram a cidade de
lisboa
movidos apenas por uma idéia era ter
tempo e nesse dia quando chegaram ao
cemitério dos prazeres enfrentar campa
dos de fontana vários tomaram a palavra
para reivindicar a reivindicar uma e
idéias simples que estava a ser
reivindicado ao mesmo tempo em vários
pontos do mundo nesse primeiro 1º de
maio de 1890 e essa ideia era simples
tempo era a idéia de que num dia de 24
horas
nós devemos ter oito horas para
trabalhar oito horas para descansar e
oito horas para fazermos o resto é o
resto é nossa vida é o coeficiente de
humanidade se quisermos algo que nos faz
humanos rir descansar namorar e ver um
filme ouvir uma conferência ficará para
conversar com alguém conhecer alguém ir
ver um copo que seja ler depois em 1991
pela primeira vez o governo ver
monarquia em portugal na altura fixou a
primeira vez o limite de oito horas de
trabalho diário
entretanto passaram mais de 100 anos
há muitas máquinas já robôs podem fazer
muitas das tarefas que nós poderíamos
deixar de fazer todos muito mais riqueza
mas a pergunta que podemos fazer é tempo
temos mais tempo para viver
o proxy que parece que não há muita
gente hoje portugal que trabalha mais do
que oito horas e sobretudo a uma
porcentagem muito grandes diz esgotada
pelo trabalho e algumas armadilhas por
exemplo estes nossos amigos que além de
terem baterias péssimas ano foram
apresentados como aliados da nossa
liberdade e nós aceitamos que essa era
uma verdade mas nos disseram que eles
podiam ser também trevas eletrônicas
nós hoje podemos levar o trabalho para
qualquer lugar fazer o trabalho em
qualquer espaço a qualquer hora
e na verdade nesse contexto de uma
espécie de obesidade digital em que nós
temos que estar sempre conectados
parece que nos exigem o que nós nos
dirigimos o dever de estar uns tempos
disponíveis nomeadamente para o trabalho
o problema é que temos menos tempo
nomeadamente menos tempo para viver para
fazer essas outras coisas que nos fazem
humanos
o problema é tão nocivo proporções tão
grave que em alguns países começou a
achar que era preciso fazer alguma coisa
sobre isto e que não bastava dizer às
pessoas vocês têm o direito de desligar
que era preciso estabelecer regras sobre
o dever de desconexões por parte das
organizações na manhã decidiu que entre
esta tarde às sete da manhã os
servidores da empresa eram desligados
para garantir que ninguém que se uma
mensagem ou inclusivo e que ninguém
tenha a tentação estiver também não
chega a espantar uma mensagem em frança
no início deste ano entrou em vigor uma
lei chamada lei da desconexão também
partir desse princípio não basta nós
dizemos desliga porque se o ambiente for
que ninguém desliga eu fico sempre na
dúvida o meu colega vai desligar ou não
vamos sentir culpado se não estiver
disponível até pode ser sujeito a alguma
opção onde raça que não sou um bom
trabalhador não estivesse disponível
ligado e por isso fizeram uma lei
a questão da lei é curiosa uma das
coisas que mais me fascinou no teatro
oprimido foi o teatro legislativo do que
a dos motivos é que funciona nós fazemos
uma peça essa peça apresenta um problema
mas não apresenta a solução desse
problema
ou seja é basicamente uma pergunta sobre
a forma teatro e nós apresentamos essa
peça
depois pedimos às pessoas que viram esse
problema que intervenham e que nos digam
o que poderia ser feito naquela situação
pra mudar e primos não apenas que elas
não porque ela nos ligou mas que nos
mostrem agindo ou seja que roubam a
quarta parede com os para hoje aqui
também e que entra em cena que mostra
como é que podia ser diferente
em 2008 como um conjunto amigos nós
montamos uma peça sobre os problemas dos
estudantes bolsas da ação social a opção
para fazer empréstimos
as dificuldades associadas a isso
montamos essa peça e vamos apresentá lo
e as pessoas entravam em cena e tentavam
diferentes funções havia sempre alguém
que pedir ajuda a uma professora havia
alguém que nossa situação social e pedir
o recálculo da bolsa é havia sempre
alguém que a seleção do estudantes dce
arranjar uma solução para resolver seu
problema
a dificuldade é que nós enfrentávamos
sempre uma barreira é que na melhor das
hipóteses nós conseguimos resolver o
problema daquela personagem específica
nós nunca conseguimos resolver o
problema que impeça apresentava que era
haver penas muito altas e haver falta de
bolsas porque porque nossa barreira era
uma lei e por isso não estávamos perante
um problema individual
estávamos perante um problema político
então nós começamos a colher sugestões
sobre o que poderia mudar na lei para
resolver o problema é que nós tínhamos
estava tarde neve estava no último ano
na altura da faculdade e começamos a
colher sugestões que temos centenas de
sugestões e depois fizemos uma sessão
com todas as pessoas pra convidamos
todas as suas linhas está a assistir às
peças escolhemos as três questões mais
importantes que as pessoas consideram
mais importantes de alterações podiam
resolver aqui o problema tem alterações
no lecs e provarmos essas alterações
assembléia decidimos fazer uma petição e
descobrimos uma coisa curiosa
não sei se você estava enquanto as
pessoas aqui é preciso ensinar que se
nenhuma petição para que essa posição
seja analisada no parlamento uma pessoa
se houver uma edição com uma pessoa a
assinar
tem que haver um deputado que faz um
relatório sobre o assunto no parlamento
e se houver mais de quatro mil
assinaturas
essa opção é automaticamente agendada no
plenário e os partidos devem apresentar
propostas de lei para em com as suas
soluções possíveis para que o problema
não estou a dizer que não possa haver
coisas que nós podemos fazer sozinhos a
gestos individuais quisermos que tem às
vezes o poder de desafiar sistemas
inteiros da opção
um dos exemplos históricos mais
conhecidos é provavelmente de rosa parks
aquela senhora negra que em 55 apanhou a
tocar depois de um dia de trabalho no
alabama estados unidos apanhou o
autocarro e cansada se sentou nos bancos
em que era proibido os negros sentarem
se a lei só de branco é que podiam
sentar em história vocês conhecem ela
sentou se ao momento em que a tocar
peixe branco estão de pé o motorista
para tocar lhe dizem que ela tem que
sair dali ela e as outras pessoas negras
que estavam sentadas
houve três que saíram e ela ficou na
verdade ela estava sentada e não
costumava ver da janela
o homem estava mas o motorista chamou a
polícia ela foi presa e disse que esse
gesto desobediência da nossa parte foi o
que iniciou o movimento pela igualdade
racial nos estados unidos mas não é
verdade
será que foi só esse gesto na verdade
esse gesto fez primeiro o sistema porque
se tornou conhecido e tornou se
conhecido no dia em que elas existem foi
presa
o movimento aquela potência imprimiu 35
mil panfletos a claro boicote aos
autocarros volvo milhares de pessoas
negras que aderiram este boicote
duzentos dias e ao fim de 300 dias
devemos ou não mudou apenas por seu
gesto mas porque via organizações no
terreno que ela fazia parte foram
capazes de transformar esse gesto em
movimento e isso vai voltar a senhora do
tipo médio
quando ela está em frente ao espelho é
pensar se vai pôr um vestido ou não
o conflito que ela tem não é apenas um
conflito consigo mesmo
é um conflito com a sociedade toda a
memória dentro da cabeça dela e fora
também com o pai eo pai disse
com os anúncios de televisão com as
músicas com a educação também deu conta
disso namorado com o senhor do metro que
a seed ou com uma lei que protege ou não
as protege se ela for vítima de assédio
como precisava ou não das pessoas como
nós que vão estar a assistir essa cena e
que vão decidir ignorar ou fazer alguma
coisa e portanto uma decisão tão sua
quanto por um estilo ou não produtiva é
na verdade uma decisão que não depende
apenas entender apenas em si mas as
condições que nós criamos coletivamente
enquanto sociedade para que ela possa em
condições de igualdade e de liberdade de
fazer as suas escolhas
enquanto eu quero chegar provavelmente
já o perceberam é que nem para nos
mudarmos a nós próprios
nós conseguimos fazer sozinhos pensar de
nós próprios
é um desafio interessante aliás é a
garantia de que não somos polícias na
nossa cabeça a pensar por nós próprios
nesta beleza ea ansiedade da política é
que nem nos mudarmos a nós próprios nos
campos e por isso mais interessantes
mais exigente mais transformador do que
pensarmos por nós próprios é pensar os
junto com outros transforma mudarmos a
vida não é
um prazer solitário
[Aplausos]